moving on to what appears to be another  ugly split Lisa Marie Presley versus  husband number four Michael Lockwood  it's been revealed that they split over  money her lawyer claims he took  advantage of her financially a source  close to the Presley family reportedly  claims Elvis's daughter was surprised to  discover things like a credit card bill  for a hundred and nine thousand dollars  the couple did have a postnup she also  wants him to have monitored visits and  is asking for full custody only problem  is Michael apparently moved out a while  ago without a forwarding address and  Lisa hasn't been able to serve him  divorce papers Lockwood did not respond  for our request for comment